voici les vedettes de twitch c'est une
plateforme de diffusion de jeux vidéo
qui a été racheté en août dernier pour
un milliard de dollars par le géant
amazon c'est un homme bon soir mathieu
cellules dites nous un peu plus là
surtout oui mais ce qu'on vient de voir
ce sont des joueurs de jeux vidéo qui se
filme dans leur sous-sol et ils sont
regardés par des millions personnes
c'est ce tweet les chiffres de twitch
pour 2014 ont été publiés la semaine
dernière et plus et ça donne le tournis
100 millions de visiteurs uniques par
mois qui regardent des contenus créés
comme ces deux gars là qu'on a vu en à
1.5 millions on les appelle les
streamers qui créent ces contenus la
sepa pourriez donc que la plateforme a
été acheté un milliard de dollars 680
employés c'est pas tranquille un
milliard de dollars par amazon c'est
dire qu'il ya des enjeux très grand en
arrière de ça et ils diffusent aux
ciseaux ce site de grands événements oui
comme par exemple le esport qu'on
appelle ça de esport dans le passeport
électronique la finale d'un des jeux les
plus populaires sur la plateforme donc
league of legends en 2013 a eu un record
qui était fracassée par seuil plus de 32
millions de personnes qui ont regardé la
finale de ce pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur le super bowl cette année là
été regardé par 110 millions personnes à
la télé dont 3 millions en ligne donc on
va vraiment fossé générationnel c'est
dix fois plus de gens qui regardent en
ligne que la finale du super bowl et ce
fossé générationnel ne retrouve pas
seulement sur tout et non mais il faut
vraiment voir sedan 1-1 grand des
grandes tendances culturelles plus large
le mekhzen vara et il était dernier a
publié un sondage vraiment très
intéressant chez les 13 à 18 ans où on
s'intéressait finalement aux vedettes de
ces gens là on s'est rendu compte que
parmi les trois premières positions chez
les jeunes aux états unis mais ce n'est
pas des gens qui venaient ni d'hollywood
donné de la télé mais c'est des youtube
heures dont des gens qui ont dit des
comptes sur youtube dont un suédois qui
est le compte le plus suivi au monde
l'on parle comparé à cnn pour parer à
toutes les grandes plateformes il est
suivi par 34 millions de personnes 8
milliard de visionnements et qu'est-ce
qu'il fait sa gueule
cuny paille c'est son nom félix québec
ellsberg et bien c'est un cronica de
jeux vidéo qui se filme dans son sous
sol il fait 4 millions de dollars en
revenus par année
sk des québécois qui sont surtout et
c'est oui on pourra retrouver par
exemple denis talbot qu'on a connue chez
monsieur net qui est un des grands
spécialistes
vidéo québec diffuse une émission qui
s'intéresse aux jeux vidéo sur cette
plateforme là mais on a aussi par
exemple des joueurs est le joueur le
plus connu au québec en fait c'est une
joueuse s'appelle stéphanie harvey élu
pour sa part 65000 personnes et elle est
quand même assez populaire à un tel
point imaginer lé travail chez ubisoft
et elle me disait qu'elle fait plus de
plus d'argent à diffuser les parties
parce que c'est une championne du monde
du jeu counter strike
elle fait plus d'argent à diffuser ces
partis sur twitter que l'argent qu'elle
fait dans sa chanson son vrai travail
entre guillemets pendant ses loisirs
effet plus d'argent c'est donc dire que
la société du loisir
elle existe en tout cas chez cette
catégorie de gens là c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi que quinze au pays un
milliard de dollars pour une plateforme
comme twitch c'est populaire
probablement c'est un peu c'est
fascinant mais un peu décourageant pour
le nôtre nous or comme on n'est pas au
plaisir